Huge move out this morning. Double top.
I didn't want to short because the trend
is so bullish,
but I want to see how it essentially
reacts to this level. Is it going to
essentially bottom here or is it going
to continue lower and we get more
downside? Uh, I think that's more of a
move that I'm more interested in. I
mean, on a one minute chart, these
candlesticks are huge.
So, we broken this downtrend. I don't
know if could be another downtrend right
here.
Trading a little longer than normal, but
I'm kind of making a conscious decision
that
there is a lot of movement right now to
continue trading.
I think the NASDAQ and ES I've I've
you know hindsight it's like oh I wish I
got in here but there's just so much
chop here it just makes it more likely
we come down here and
you know have difficulty continuing
lower. Now that could be totally false
and we just continue lower. Um but I
think I'd rather focus on gold here.
I need more of a pullback though. It
needs to come down to here essentially
like retest this. I want to see it
retest this. And if it doesn't do that,
then I I'll get out or I'll be done for
the day.
Would I go long right here? It's It's a
pullback. It would be nice to get a
little bit more just to get a really
good idea like okay it's faked lower you
know make sure that this is failed
because otherwise this could just be a
continuation lower you know big picture
could be
it bounces here
and it pushes lower,
but I also don't think I can really wait
for more confirmation. It's made a nice
higher low off of this area I've looked
for. It's a double bottom head and
shoulders, I mean, off of this
um
previous high here. Nice bounce there
and then a bounce here. So that's pretty
dang good structure. My kind of
the only thing is I feel like my
intuition is kind of saying that this is
um it's already had two big moves for
the day
and so
it might just kind of
start to go a little sideways.
um seems unlikely that it's going to
continue up,
but it's also hard to say when gold has
just been so bullish.
You know, these fair value gaps feel
like good targets.
Okay, just going to be patient and and
see what happens. Overall setup is good.
It just may take a while.
Pretty scary spike there. Not really
much I can do. Just letting things play
out, you know, on a 15-minute. I think
it's a good spot. still
just nervous about
trade not working out just because I'm
on a downswing
and you know maybe a little frustration
over the fact that I
kind of saw this short on the NASDAQ and
ES and didn't take it because I was
thinking that it would be tricky and
unlikely to really play out.
Um, but it didn't really show what I
wanted. You know, it just I don't really
like slow reversals like that. They just
don't work very well. I want to see more
structure like this, like head and
shoulders, clear moves.
Um, I find they're they're just more
likely to work out. And so in hindsight,
seeing it work sucks, but also
um it it wasn't a trade I wanted. So
accepting that and being happy about
that. And I'm just nervous about this
gold trade just because um it is a
little later than I normally take a
trade and it feels like uh could just be
getting choppy, but also
I'm just nervous because I'm scared
about the outcome. You know, what if it
loses here?
But, you know, again, the reasons to get
in were solid,
and that's that's what I want to be
focusing on, right? It's not about the
trade outcome. It's about the process of
executing when it's
follows your strategy and and pushing
through that nervousness and emotion and
not letting that control you.
Man, this is a serious
chop fest. I'm just trying to wait it
out. watch from my phone. Um, looking at
it, I mean,
big picture, trying to be unbiased.
Like, it just looks like it's just
gonna,
you know, it could just chop here, but
it could just, you know, the trend could
just grind it higher. So, I'm not going
to go break even yet until it,
you know, breaks out, I think, of this
this range it's in. My stop's in a good
spot.
Okay, that's a pretty nice breakout. At
this point, I'm going to move to break
even
because I think if it pulls back, um,
you know, I want to get out. Uh,
it, you know, it could totally come up
here and
slow down. Um, kind of what I'm looking
at is, you know, it bouncing off these
highs or this previous low being an
issue. Um, I'd love to get 3x,
but you know, it might just take a while
to get up there. It's got going, which
is really nice,
but it's not at a point where I want to
take anything off yet. It's nice to be
up money for once, having a trade
actually work out. Uh,
but, you know, again, I'm looking for a
larger move here, and I want to at least
target try and target 3x moneywise in
terms of trying to like feel uh good
contentwise.
be nice to be hit over 5K. Uh but again,
I'm just going to go with what the
market's showing me. And right now, I
think it's it's at this spot where we
might slow down. We might come down and
and bounce off this previous high uh and
then continue higher. So, just, you
know, going to keep
waiting it out, you know, uh stopped in
a good spot. And while we wait for this
trade, I just want to let you know Ninja
Trader is having something they call the
Ninja Trader Arena Cup. There is
$400,000
worth of money in the prize pool to get
and you can sign up with this link below
and it's three feeder tournaments with
$50,000 prize pool each into a $250,000
prize pool. So, there's multiple dates
that you can participate and try and get
into that huge $250,000 tournament. I'll
leave a link below or you can click on
this QR code to join and find out more
information. So, we are definitely
starting to get going here. I'm just
trying to see if there's kind of an
uptrend here. Um
I I mean I think likely I'll probably
just literally just get out of my limit
order if we get up there because looking
at the highs
uh kind of dragging both those over
those are those are here. Um, I mean,
this is a insanely healthy trend if you
think about it. Uh, you know, pullback,
moved up, chopped for a long time, and
then moved up. And if it's just going to
grind higher, I would love to stay in
it. But also, um, trends like this can
just have a snapback. Uh, and giving a
lot of that up would suck. Um, and so
I'm just distracting myself. I'm
literally downstairs uh taking apart my
vacuum cleaner and just cleaning it out,
you know, just doing something
meticulous
and that just allows me to kind of sit
in this trade and kind of let it do what
it needs to do. If it breaks this down
uptrend though, I don't think I'm going
to get out just because of how healthy
it is. I think it it could totally just,
you know, it could have a pullback to to
these highs right here, you know. Um,
again, I think the big picture looks
really good. If it starts to, you know,
get something going in terms of changing
what it's doing, then I'll maybe come
back and and and think about getting
out. But at the moment, um, you know, I
think it looks solid to just keep gr
grinding higher and and I'm happy to be
in
for that.
Okay, this pullback definitely doesn't
look great.
Um, but I need to see kind of what it
does. I mean, it's just so unlikely that
it just, you know, the fear is, oh, it
just rips all the way down here.
unlikely, you know, um
it's more likely that we I I want to see
how it hits this bottom because, you
know, again, looking on a fivem minute,
it's just a slow chug higher.
And so, it's hard to not overmanage in
spots like this or or get scared by
flushes like this when it could just
like it's doing right now, hopefully
just pop right back up. Um, I think if
it makes a new high here though,
I'll move my stop here. If it
starts to go like this or something,
I'm going to stop here. Something like
that.
Okay, there's another spike lower
hitting this low.
that could be a a break of this trend.
Now, I need to see a couple candlesticks
and see what it does. Um, but I think at
this point I'll move my stop loss up to
here at least.
I would really
be kind of upset to get out here.
It's giving room to see if that spike
gets reversed, but
looks like it's not.
Damn. I mean, that's just part of
trading.
It looks so close to getting like a
really big win. Um,
but you know, getting out here still I
was happy with how I traded. I think I
stayed in it. You know, getting out
somewhere up here would have just been,
I think, kind of, I don't know, more
emotional and just because the trend was
still in play. there's no reason to get
out based on the charts until now. Um,
so still a nice trade. Nice to get a
something in the books, but bummer that,
you know, to get knocked out here
because part of me is like, oh, it looks
like it could just knock out and then
reverse. But, you know, that's that's
the signal I'm going with, and I'm going
to call it a day on